I think I said hard work dedication
resilience and faith its resilience you
know you you build a business it takes
five years it may take a lot of mistakes
especially in a space where no one has
been my financial service company was a
very unique idea I mean how Walmart's
doing it now the people are doing it but
when i started my financial service
company for underserved communities
there was no such thing and so we were
made many mistakes and and we knew there
was profit a margin or possibility for
profit and margin but in the beginning
it was a lot of education and a lot of
learning that no one had learned there's
no book that could teach us how to make
that card that business successful how
to provide health care for these
underserved communities or provide loans
for them or card the card transfers he's
kind of this whole process that we're
undertaking out all new and so doing it
requires a little trial and error a lot
of resilience and you know have an idea
and even if no one's done it it's kind
of good that no one's done it but it's a
little harder because of it a little bit
more it's a little bit more learning
process that you know new information
not available anywhere and an idea
that's not been explored and that's kind
of been my you know the thing that's
made me most inspired about being in
business man that is a creative process
it's an instinctual thing you know it's
also creative and cultural thing and all
of my businesses that's been the poetry
no one thought that poetry made good
sense you know on mainstream television
no one thought black comedy that you put
five black comedians on every week and
have the highest rated show on HBO they
just didn't think that made good sense
I'm repeating it because it's just such
a bookmark you know it's in every case
there was a void and it was never a
support system I went to work not
because I wanted to build a business but
because I wanted to distribute an idea a
design a you know a sound you know it
was always that kind of motivation and
just to let people express themselves
many cases I was just a manager of a
creative process